قصف جديد عرضت له مدينه دنيتك صباح هذا
اليوم
وهذا القصف الذي استهدف مركز المدينه
وتمثل في سقوط صواريخ تقول مصادر هنا على
انها من طراز هيمرس احد هذه الصواريخ خلف
هذه الحفره وترون عمقها ما يؤكد على ان
هذه الصواريخ يمكن ان تكون بالفعل من طراز
هاي مارس امريكيات الصنع وهذه هي الحفره
الثانيه وطبعا شظايا هذين الصاروخين طالع
البنايات المجاوره بالنسبه للمكان فهنا
يوجد او توجد مدرسه لتعليم الموسيقى
وتؤكد السلطات هنا على انه لا يوجد اي مقر
عسكري حول هذا المكان اي مكان القصف طبعا
ليست هناك اي معلومات حتى الان عن سقوط
ضحايا لكن رئيس دنيس كالموالي لروسيا امس
كان قد من تصعيد اوكراني محتمل مع اقتراب
الذكرى الاولى لما تطلق عليه روسيا
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا وايضا مع
حلول هذا اليوم الثالث والعشرين من فبراير
وهو عيد حماه الوطن اي عيد الجيش في روسيا